[Music]
you're both in the business and you're
both actors and you're married you got
kids what happens when one of you has
got to shoot a love scene or a sex scene
what do you do you tell that's been
about it no you just don't tell them no
I mean wait till he sees it in the
theater
you'd be like you're gonna love this
next part I tried that version it
doesn't work no I you know what I have
no problem with if it happens it happens
and on screen it doesn't bother me
whatsoever doesn't bother him whatsoever
but I don't necessarily want to see it
live take after take after take
and so like and neither does he so if
it's one of those days where you have to
have a love scene I just asked him
politely stay home and he's like totally
like it does not even a question about
it I just don't want it you don't to see
your partner like getting it off with
someone else for 12 hours it's weird you
guys but on-screen it really is
especially if the hors d'oeuvres aren't
good I would think it'd be I know that
if I were an actor and I had a scene
with like a beautiful woman that has
gonna be you know having a sex scene
with her I wouldn't want my wife there
but I would invite everyone I went to
high school to high-five oh you said I
never make it exactly what happens
that's how I do it yeah how you do it
yeah I mean the grips are high fiving
that went really well yeah I think that
really really well
you